et nous ont rejoint
Patricia Bardi Miss France 1980 a pris
le Benaim première dauphine on le sait
et puis
Fatima Benamar qui est membre du
collectif nous toutes merci d'être avec
nous parce qu'on fait un petit débat
quand même et vous avez animé les miss
vous bien sûr pendant plusieurs années
on fait un débat sur 5 ans parce que les
Miss France aujourd'hui sur la 3 c'était
sur la 3 absolument est-ce que les miss
abîme ou pas l'image de la femme on a
repassé à une image de de je sais pas
comment s'appelle promo comment
s'appelle l'émission
et regarder de repasser notamment une
image d'une interview qu'on faisait à
l'époque des Miss France est-ce que ça
vous choque pas regarder
Miss France je vous l'avais promis en
début de ce journal et bien la voici
alors des chiffres les mensurations vous
faites combien on commence par le haut
on finit par un peu plus bas alors
70-85 de poitrine 85 de 1 et 65 de
taille
à l'époque c'est quand même assez dingue
l'image de la femme aujourd'hui est-ce
que voilà si on a un peu féministe il
faut arrêter les Miss France c'est la
question finalement non en fait ce que
ce qui m'interpelle en fait dans le
concours Miss France c'est
qu'effectivement on est censé
représenter enfin la femme qui
représente on va dire la France alors on
sait plus exactement si c'est la plus
belle femme de France ou parce qu'il y a
aussi des concours tout simplement de
culture générale etc et c'est vrai que
ce que je trouve choquant encore en 2022
c'est qu'on est des critères tellement
oppressants sur leur gabarit sur leur
taille sur leur morphologie mais aussi
sur leur mœurs quelque part c'est à dire
qu'on est encore dans ce stéréotype de
la petite fiancée
entre il faut qu'elles aient un âge
maximum ça serait pas une Miss France
sinon en fait c'est toute l'ambiguïté
c'est-à-dire que si en fait l'idée c'est
de dire est-ce que la plus belle femme
de France ne peut pas être tatouée ne
peut pas être divorcé pourquoi doit être
célibataire non parce qu'il y a tout un
alors
tu peux ne serait-ce que des poussières
et par ailleurs c'est pas avoir de
prendre un chargeur je pense que ce sera
toujours intéressant que ce soit les
miss qui essaient de d'échanger entre
elles et peut-être de revendiquer une
modernisation en fait du contenu du
concours
qui a déclaré aussi les Miss France ou
les regarde juste pour le physique on
s'en fout de finalement ce qu'elle
répond de questionnaire et tout ça et ça
c'est un contexte bien sûr mais est-ce
que c'est pas un peu vrai alors Patricia
mademoiselle bon donc si on prend une
femme mariée ou comme ou les
mensurations moi par exemple j'ai été
élu Miss France quand j'avais 16 ans
j'étais Miss France en 1980 et jamais on
m'a on s'est permis de me demander des
mensurations comme on l'a fait là mais
il faut dire que j'étais mineur donc
comme j'avais toujours Geneviève de
Fontenay ma maman à mes côtés et j'ai
été très très protégée et ça a été une
très belle aventure pour moi et voilà et
je suis quelque part un petit peu
féministe c'est-à-dire donc c'est à dire
que j'aime la liberté je suis libre de
faire mes choix bien sûr c'est moi qui
ai choisi aller à Miss France
vous n'obéissez plus à tous les critères
qui sont quand même très très nombreux
imaginez vous serez tomber amoureuse au
moment de de du concours
désacraliser un peu l'émission ça reste
du divertissement les Français en sont
friands ils attendent Miss France la
preuve l'audimat monte chaque année et
moi je vois vraiment ça comme du
divertissement donc faut un peu voilà
désacraliser les missions il y a des
choses plus importantes pour
moi
l'idée c'est quand même de se dire que
aujourd'hui et peut-être vous avez un
ici aujourd'hui au moment où on est en
train de dire que voilà les féminisme la
femme légale de l'homme et tout ça et
tout ce qu'on aime le meetou va voir des
femmes comme ça qui défilent qui ne font
que défiler pour être élu comme la femme
la plus belle et qui répondent à un
questionnaire où on se moque un peu
d'elle est-ce que quelque part
aujourd'hui c'est pas complètement à
l'inverse du mouvement de ce qu'on est
en train de faire avec la femme
aujourd'hui c'est un tremplin moi si je
n'avais pas été Miss France jamais je ne
serai monté à Paris jamais je n'aurais
fait du mannequinat jamais je n'aurais
fait le tour du monde et du cinéma
de le faire en faisant par exemple du 42
et on est pas en très belle pareil
exactement
elle a été dauphine de Miss France et
ben au jour d'aujourd'hui elle est
propulsée elle fait du silencieuse de la
mode et défilés
on va empêcher une personne du jour au
lendemain après
on va nous enlever toutes les belles
choses faut arrêter alors
[Musique]
je regarde des belles choses des beaux
culs
[Applaudissements]
on se calme on se calme j'aimerais la
vie de April est-ce qu'après ça vous
choque on s'il vous plaît
on peut débrancher Laurent Laurent on a
compris ton point de vue on peut lui
donner le point de la sincérité
absolument le point la sincérité
les amis là je suis dans le droit de
réponse
ce que malheureusement on réclame depuis
plusieurs années c'est d'ouvrir un petit
peu plus les critères qu'ils soient
moins restrictif mais
qui fait du
carnet la plus belle femme de France et
quand on entend Laurent dire les plus
belles choses on veut nous enlever les
choses non ce sont pas des choses désolé
c'est pas de la viande
et je te dis d'une manière extravagante
et tout je la trouve exceptionnel et à
la spécialement 36 degrés de taille de
taille 85 de poitrine allez allez mais
Beyoncé
après s'il te plaît April pourquoi vous
dites que ça évolue cette année vous
avez pas vu ce qui s'est passé cette
année Alex elle a rejoubert a changé les
règles de Miss France bah quand même je
suis désolé il y a quand même des
évolutions je pense que c'est bien de le
noter c'est bien de le dire après on
peut pas passer du tout au tout mais ça
continuera d'évoluer sûrement
la seule évolution c'est que maintenant
elles peuvent avoir un petit copain
c'est pas rédhibitoire
c'est est-ce que quelque part pardon il
y a pas un côté un peu c'est pas moi qui
le dis mais c'est un peu petit je crois
que pendant un an vous allez être la
belle fille c'est un peu sois belle et
tais-toi c'est un peu ça le débat
finalement vous faites des interviews et
on n'écoute pas ce que vous dit non
c'est pas des questions le soir de
l'élection de vous ne savez pas répondre
aux questions vous n'êtes pas élu
cette semaine trouver normale qu'en 2021
c'était l'année dernière je pense il y a
une femme une Miss enfin le concours et
au Miss un moment elle est les maîtresse
de son corps puisqu'on parle féminisme
mais elle décide de le mettre au service
d'une belle cause qu'il a lutte contre
le cancer anaïsme
et là on a presque encore une fois une
cérémonie de répudiation
et moi je trouve que ça ce sont des
systèmes de répudiation d'une violence
pas possible il montre que on demande
pas seulement une Miss d'être belle mais
on lui se demande d'obéir aussi aux
critères de ce que censé être une femme
je trouve qu'une femme qui fait un ciné
comme ça mais là je suis tout à fait
d'accord
Déborah il y a quelque chose moi qui qui
me choque à chaque fois tous les ans
c'est ce c'est c'est ce tic qui a de
d'avoir Sylvie Tellier toujours présente
à côté d'une miss comme une chaperonne
qui vient valider tout ce qui est en
plateau attention
débordement qu'on la laisse pas parler
toute seule comme si elle ne pouvait pas
parler toute seule et moi c'est vraiment
le truc qui me dérange et je pense que
c'est juste on pouvait retirer ça et
laisser les miss aller en plateau seul
s'exprimer cette juste
aujourd'hui
je pense pas que cette vidéo ne serait
pas la Estrée là à côté de la présidente
du comité de leur Florian
moi je pense que la meilleure réponse
c'est les miss elle-même peu importe on
voit Delphine Wespiser qui est
chroniqueuse chez toi le PMP tous les
jours on voit Alexandra rosenfel qui
vient de sortir un bouquin sur le
bien-être que j'ai lu qui est vachement
bien on voit marine Lorphelin
elles deviennent toutes ces tremplin un
peu sexiste éventuellement Fatima Fatima
je t'ai laissé parler je je sais c'est
un tremplin un peu sexiste peut-être
mais regardez ce que beaucoup d'entre
elles arrivent à faire après
complexes excuse-moi faites les
complexes cette époque je tends elle
voulait rentrer dans Miss France quand
elle a quand elle a fait le concours il
y avait elle avait des critères de
beauté des choses qu'elle n'avait
comment tu peux
on parle pardon à la place des Miss on
est on a ici deux listes une première
dauphine qui sont très heureux d'avoir
fini qui ne sont pas qui ne se sentent
pas du tout victime Hugo s'il te plaît
victime de féministe et on est en train
de parler pour elle finalement
je sais plus si c'était toi Isabelle ou
c'était une autre de déco chroniqueuse
si tu te souviens on avait fait un débat
de TPMP il y avait une Miss il y avait
descendu l'institution Miss France c'est
très bien puis après on coulisse elle a
commencé à parler elle avait dit mais
qu'est-ce que j'ai été affamé pendant
cette année ça a été un sacerdoce pour
moi etc donc je pense que quand on est
en vitrine en train de défendre c'est
pas c'est évident que ça de vouloir
remettre en cause les bases de ce
concours
c'est pas cruel de dire ça mais elles
sont consentantes elles sont volontaires
elles savent que ça va être un tremplin
elle choisit de le faire donc oui
parce que pendant un an elles vont être
sur les routes et qu'on peut y perdre
son petit copain la preuve c'est que les
quasiment tout elle perd ce qu'elle
celui qu'elles ont et et et on peut
créer d'autres concours à côté pour
d'autres types de femmes pour d'autres
paysages
de téléspectateurs en 2021 ce qui fait
10 % de la population française
à part tous les gens qui on va regarder
la télé donc Miss France a un impact
énorme quand même
c'est c'est un emmerdement
c'est-à-dire que si on fait évoluer
peut-être que c'est
dans 5 qui fait du 42 et magnifique
je veux juste te dire que en Belgique si
on s'en fout de la gif de Will Smith pas
du tout de nos Miss parce que en
Belgique il faut au minimum que notre
Miss Belgique maîtrise le français le
néerlandais et aussi l'allemand parce
que les trois langues sont reconnues
comme étant langue nationale ce qui
présuppose déjà une fameuse sculpture
générale et il y a une Miss Belgique que
vous connaissez tous ici sur TF1 et qui
n'est autre que Tatiana Silva est une
très bonne copine une très bonne idée
Tatiana et voilà il faut déjà avoir une
fameuse culture pour présenter un
bulletin météo il ne suffit pas
uniquement de dire il va pleuvoir
cet exemple qu'est-ce que tu en penses
juste à manger bien est-ce que je me
pose pas toutes ces questions je pense
que ça évolue naturellement
on parle plus de mensuration du tout
aujourd'hui non
chiffres du tout déjà mais en tout cas
pour concourir il y a des monstres bien
sûr mais le vrai féminisme c'est
l'égalité des salaires c'est l'égalité
aussi dans le cinéma la littérature
c'est un divertissement il y a il y a
1000 combats plus important
qui va nous dire si on a un pays
féministe c'est un symbole c'est un
petit symbole de ce qui pèse pour que
les femmes aient l'impression d'avoir un
corps présentable beau etc et n'empêche
moi qui suis dans une association il y a
beaucoup de jeunes filles je peux
t'assurer qu'à 14 15 ans ils ont
l'impression d'avoir de voir des
monstres de dans leur miroir alors que
je leur dis non mais tu as une
morphologie
en général mais oui alors le dernier mot
pour Patricia quand même moi Patricia
voilà est-ce qu'aujourd'hui vous trouvez
que les miss c'est encore un petit peu
chaud comment est-ce que ça va encore
évoluer ou pas du tout moi je ne pense
pas que ça doit trop évoluer
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire c'est 142 bon
peut-être
je suis encore vieille France
mais moi personnellement ma liberté
c'est de ne pas avoir les tatouage parce
que moi personnellement
envie d'avoir un tatouage pourquoi pas
mais je pense pas que ça correspondent
aux critères de Miss France et je trouve
que ce serait dommage de saccager le
concours parce que là on est en train
d'essayer de saccager ce concours en
racontant qu'il faut voilà plutôt
classique
regarder en France et il y a volonté
combien de millions de téléphones vous
avez participé donc merci
[Applaudissements]
à tous